pope francis is urging the world to be
more open to dialogue this christmas in
his holiday message delivered this
morning he says that is key to resolving
the large number of conflicts and
disagreements seen in places like syria
iraq and yemen it builds upon his
thoughts he shared at midnight mass and
as christians throughout europe try to
embrace the holiday while keeping
concerns about omicron in mind roxanna
saberi has that part of the story
[Music]
despite the coveted resurgence pope
francis celebrated christmas eve mass
last night before around 2 000
worshippers more than last year far
fewer than pre-pandemic levels i think
i'm lucky to get to see this and
especially during covid you know
the faithful also gathered in bethlehem
but in limited numbers with israel's
borders shut to most international
travelers
as the omicron variant rages across
europe the netherlands has returned to a
national lockdown other countries are
opting for a lighter touch like more
testing and vaccinations in france kids
ages 5 to 11 can now get a shot
in italy and in spain people once again
have to wear masks outdoors
in england where new daily cases are
hitting record highs the government says
it will wait until after christmas to
announce any new measures
there is still a wonderful thing you can
give
your family and the whole country
and that is
to get that jab
the pandemic is preventing the royal
family from their traditional church
visit on christmas day
instead queen elizabeth is staying home
giving her christmas address from
windsor castle
while kate the duchess of cambridge
performed for the nation with scottish
singer tom walker in a christmas carol
service designed to bring people
together after another difficult year
for cbs saturday morning roxanna saberi
london